Let's look more closely to these factor variables. For
now I want to draw your attention to the age.range variable
right here. Notice that it says that we have a
factor variable with seven different levels. We can examine the
levels of a variable, by typing in the command levels
and then putting it the variable right here. In the
console we can see the seven levels of the age.range
variable. Now, instead of creating a table of the age.range
variable, let's create a plot that shows how many users
are in each bin. That is, we want to figure out how
many surveyed respondents are between the ages of 18 and
24, 25 and 34, and so on. I'm going to create this
plot using the ggplot2 package, and the qplot function that
comes with it. Again, don't worry about understanding this code too
much, we'll have practice with this in the next lesson.
When I run this code, I get my plot over here.
Zooming in on this plot, I want you to notice
that the age groups appear to be in order. This is
true for everyone except the survey takers who are under
the age of 18. Now, it would be really helpful if
this bar was really oriented over here. That way we
could make comparisons across the groups more easily. Now this is
why we would want to have ordered factors. The variable age.range just
contains factors with seven levels, but these levels aren't arranged in
any particular order. Sometimes you want to introduce order into our
data set. So that way we can make more readable plots.
So, knowing a little bit about ordered factors, let's see
if you can answer this next question. If you haven't already
done so, download the Reddit survey data and look at
its structure. After you looked at the structure of the variables,
try and answer this question. Which of these variables in
the data set could also be converted to an ordered factor?
Just like age.range.
Check any of the variables that apply.